so we're like doing a puzzle we just  started it so there's like a thousand  pieces laying all over the kitchen table  I'm doing the edge pieces and she she  was like do you want the picture  and I was like no I don't need it she  was like oh you're just gonna raw dog it  and I was like  what and my sister was like Mom don't  say that and she's like oh I I don't  know what it means I've just heard other  people say that  I was like never say that again she  looks right in my face I was like so  you're just gonna raw dog it  mom what Helen keep saying it so no keep  saying ever say it Greg say it both of  you say it no just everything it was  scarring yeah it's gonna raw dog this  sandwich we were kind of saying it like  as a joke afterwards yeah we kept using  it as a family yeah  it's a little family inside joke now  I'd like to break that one reverse  family joke